time and time again I have practiced
delayed gratification and it ends up
working in my favor it's basically being
able to say I can afford this I can have
this item that I want but I am not ready
to spend on it right now and I can tell
you so many times this has happened to
me where I end up purchasing that item
that I really wanted for a much cheaper
price this has happened to me for with a
pair of sandals that I had wanted that
cost around $100 and I ended up finding
them for six bucks at a thrift store I
had wanted a pair of jewelry
a new set of earrings that I had been
wanting for a long time and I kept
myself from buying them and my mom
actually had a pair that she ended up
giving to me this was unexpected I had
never even mentioned it to her in the
past this just happened to me today I
had seen this cute little dish at a
different store and I thought I don't
know what I'd do with it but I love it
so beautiful so I'm not going to spend
money on it right now and I ended up
finding it at a thrift store has this
ever happened to you or is it just me
delayed gratification works and it works
in your favor